[Music]
yes
uh not sure
apologies from
19 response updates so um first minute
uh being on the agenda library upgrading
i believe we have um the community is
going to
speak to us prisoners that have all been
given
uh miranda thomas
or gardening club um
i'm um the secretary as well as the
community
and it is a great concern that we cannot
use the facility that was
put together for the community and it
was so convenient
because the schools could walk to it and
we had great participation
from the schools coming along to the
show and the nearest venue that's big
enough for us now
is the talent company
it is concerned that we also know that
the report
that gives council the okay to go ahead
with what they're doing
is um dated 2008
the one from mr bannerman
and in that
um it was to take over the two rooms
here at the top
that was what he was permission to do
[Music]
floor of the james um week and that's
what his whole report is based around
and energy said that the proposal was
likely to see me
a semi-permanent it isn't permanent to
see me
and that this proposal for them to move
up here for the two rooms
was um did not amount to a substantial
deviation from the purposes
um for which the day's coming was
established so we're only talking about
the two rooms
at the top
and that the james coming the whole
building
um was for the establishment maintenance
of the hall
or other meeting places for farmers and
for educational societies
and um indicated various types of
implementations which were intended to
receive the benefit
of the pool and so they went here saying
there's going to be a civic
administration building
a civic theatre an hourly citizen centre
wintry botanical gardens and the james
coming where
it is evident that the proposed james
[ __ ] women was planning to provide
all the facilities envisaged by the lake
was coming in as well
there is a need to establish that it has
in fact become impossible and practical
or expedient to carry out the charitable
process of the trust and respect of
which the scheme has been prepared
that's what decided when asked about the
two rooms and that council
do have it is their jurisdiction and
they get all the funds from it
it has been held that the court owes
duty to those proposed to be benefited
by the trust
and to the public generally to dispose
of the trust fund or property
as nearly as possible in accordance with
the charitable purposes of the trust
in such a way it will best serve the
interest of those who
tended to be benefited
and that said his final conclusions
are that we would not go so far as to
say that the council may totally
disregard the purposes for which the
james coming
was established when making decisions
about the use
and management of the facility
in our opinion the proposed use of two
rooms to accommodate staff would not
substantially undermine the purposes
for which the james coming was
established
so as users of the
james coming for many years the garden
club has never been
consulted and never been asked about
it and in fact when we first came and
said look
will we still be able to have a show
here they said
not probably this year but um
maybe it could be about 18 months was
the initial thing
to do the library and put them back
where they were
so that the general public could keep
this amazing facility and so i would
like the council to consider
um what they're doing because it isn't a
lack of consultation and we would really
like it to stay as a community center
thank you okay
sorry sorry yeah
just uh i'll just open it up to the
questions obviously first question
by him thank you for the submission um
first question
we've had one one of the events
but is it used it's obviously the other
rooms yes
and often that's the whole complex that
we fly around
yeah yeah and that's an annual yes
every february
[Music]
is
but we use the other rooms yes yes so
am i right not
yes right so using tnc do you use the
tncl from there only
only because we can't use this oh okay
yes
so that was last year yes oh we did use
it there before we had a combined
new zealand daily um national daily show
confines our show
and it wasn't enough and we use the
country but normally
it is too big for our show on its own
yeah
and it's also out of town so the
children can't repair from
across the road and from full main and
they
they support it and they put in lots of
entries and then on a saturday they
bring all these folks so it's a really
big part of our show to come
for the community as well yep
any other questions from councillors
participates obviously that document
being referred to yet has been
attached to the uh
[Music]
um
address us on
[Music]
i think the first thing to emphasize
here is that
we are as we know living and working in
uh extraordinary times and code 19 has
thrown those those up so
this particular project that's now
before the council
really come to come into view as a
result of
cover 19 and the government's shuttle
reading initiatives
those initiatives were framed
very rapidly following the level four
decision
uh announced only 23rd of march and
enacted
on 25th of march and
it was towards the end of that month uh
we believe early april
that we got um we accounted for staff
um wind of the government initiative of
shovel ready
uh application performance higher than
the next few days
and it was pretty much about 10 days
maximum
that we had to compile business cases
on what was dealing with each other's
projects
i spent a time report mr chairman just
talking about the evolution of
the library and these issues and how it
came to dean and james coming
and the the key point which i guess i
need to
make that answers in part some concerns
of the
speaking you just have for you is that
the application
student government made the point that
while library
design was reasonably uh we're
pretty confident that we can produce
that reason quickly
the issue of the range of community
space that would need to be encompassed
in this project
of the conversation with the community
so a good power support is talking about
that conversation
and it goes to how what does that
community space look like
um in terms of numbers of rooms
size of rooms and analyzing
the need for those rooms
now that 50 years has passed since the
design of james king wing was
put forward and close to 60 years has
passed since the
interpretation of james come and build
is provided
in the will itself which was granted
probate
in 1946 so put those dates out there to
just show how long it has been
since those initial intentions
um well founded and founded as they were
of trustees and the deceased person
himself
and questions i guess to overlay this
is around what is the
contemporary needs of communities in
2020 and how can they still be
secured uh having regards the spirit
of the original twist
so there's a lot of christians in this
chairman around what the
community may need um we live in a very
urgent
and somewhat perfect world and
the notion that the government think the
government would give
this council some of three million
dollars
or a library project or in the
communities project
is unheard of in my time of government
which now stands for
30 years so i put that
out there to just appreciate
i think the importance of the decision
that we've been given by the government
and secondly the need to crack on the
government
before making its announcements in touch
with me
orally and wanted to tease this approach
along with the mlt event center uh and
want
assurances that it was indeed shuttle
ready
and i did certainly given the cable that
still needed to be consultation
engagement with the committee on the
community room aspect
along with design features in the new
library
so the expectation government is that we
will move quickly
and hence the timetable in the report
sets out a fairly ratified process but
a very dedicated process for community
engagement with details of which
uh communications management google is
here to
answer more detailed questions about it
there may be some questions around
project budget again
these um determine them on two things
one is the feedback from the community
in regard to
engaging process and features that may
be sought
by the community and then incorporating
the project
the other is that we need to be upfront
here that when we put forward this
proposal to the government
we only have a rough order of cost based
on square marriage
uh and the pages are defeated somewhat
by the experience of next
or pacific administration building
upgrade so the 5.5 million
rough order cost is that and really
it won't get firmed until such times we
have a firm design
which is dependent again on the engaging
process of communities
if i keep coming back to engage in the
process of the community
it really is because it's important um
a part of the project needs to be done
well we need to get the right
feedback to get this right but that
doesn't
uh suggest in our view that it has to be
elongated
and bogged down with paralysis by our
analysis
we just need to have a user-friendly
process uh that both
digital platform hard copies or people
who put forth their views
and then we can then work with the
design team
to arrive at hopefully what is an
optimal solution
that pleases most people most of the
time
um that's probably a nutshell um
um it's an exciting project but it's
challenging
on a number of fronts uh one of which i
think will be
the notion of what we've always had
versus what we might be able to have
through imagination
and a little bit of
courageousness in terms of that like
just encouraging approaches
the various
sections of the providers will be here
in front of us
[Music]
thomas as well the fact that there was
an emphasis on feedback of the community
and the consultation process that's
going to take place in regards
to the community i'm just prior to
starting one question
um garden the two rooms that were taken
over
they are the new council building is
refreshing
memory they
administration bill design was on the
basis that all
staff of gdc are repatriated back to
that building okay
so just open up the discussion amongst
the um
thank you through the chair i just asked
the eo
the community consultation do we have a
time frame on that
[Music]
there's no statutory time frame set
but the only time frame is that we're
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you
thank you mr chairman now i've got uh
great concerns about this
first of all i've got concerns about the
5.5 million
project at a rough order of cost we've
already seen once before a project
that's
escalated out of control
and we haven't seen any planes we
haven't seen a thing
and i'm very concerned about what i see
in front of me
the other thing that i question that i
ask is how do we
bring forward the 1.1 million for the
roof
repair of the existing library
into this project what happens to the
library
who pays for it to get it the roof
repaired
the library building
will be the subject of another report
and process uh in terms of its future
use
uh yesterday the interview still remains
um but i
only referenced that amount is that that
was the location the council had its
current
ltp uh which was associated with the
library activity great
that's great so how do we bring forward
that money to this project
why are we allowed to uh through you mr
chairman because
one sum of 1.1 million was allocated to
a library building
to future proof that activity
so my analysis that's allocated to
the library activity if the council
wanted to re-allocate that funds
for another library project but not on
that site
that would seem to be in order in terms
of how you
you look at your significance engagement
policy in terms of spending money on the
live
upgrade you mr look don't get me wrong
here
i congratulate the staff for getting the
three million what concerns me
is the rest of the money that we have to
find you know we haven't got a
bottomless pit of money
the ratepayers are struggling now all of
a sudden
we're going to spend 5.5 million less to
1.1
because we have to replace the roof at
the library
to make the building either sellable or
used
in some way so technically we've only
got
4.4 million
sorry just
in my mind but i think council's got
a couple of challenges in front and we
all know
only too well the limitations and
the
[Music]
and we know that it's a responsibility
to
to provide a service both a library
service
and a meeting room service
for the community so i think that in my
mind the critical thing is
um connecting with the community now
with some options
that would include potential funding
options
um to talk about what the desire of the
community is
and and while we've only got a short
time
um i think that we do need to
to make haste um because
um the basis of the three million
dollars
and this shouldn't be totally driven by
three million dollars
it is going to be an influence there's
no doubt about that the basis of three
million dollars is it's ready to go
so we need to know what the general
feeling
of the community is and and i know
that the building for both buildings
actually both the library building and
the james coming
um were designed and built
in an age that is a number of years ago
and and the world has it's slightly
altered
in the way that we use some of those
services
in this current time and
i know the use of the hall
i know the use rates of the hall
i know that the opportunities and the
challenges that the current
library the previous library
had and and looking at what is
um provided in other communities and the
use that
those those facilities get as compared
to the use
of the service here and and whatever we
do
and i'm very mindful that whatever we do
won't be decided here today it'll be
started after we talk to the community
whatever we do really has to be
proofing us for the future for the next
30 or 40 years
and even if we look back 30 years ago
the needs and purposes of of
both those properties has changed
significantly
and looking forward i'm sure that
um the changes will be even as
dramatic in the future as they have been
in the past so i think that the critical
thing here is now
um let's talk to the community about
what we think the options are
and if they if the community stares
in great britain but we either agree
with that
or we don't agree with that then we
should take that on board
sorry thank you worshipper
mr i understand all this
right i understand what we're going to
be doing for the future what i don't
understand
is the money that we're having tomorrow
to do this project
and and here and why is my problem we
can't afford it
if i gave you the if i gave you the
million dollars
i'll make it up to a million dollars no
problem at all with the with the mbm
fund and the three if you can't do the
project inside that
then we shouldn't do it that may be one
of my constraints
[Music]
i don't see i don't see that here mr
chairman i don't see that here as one of
the recommendations
and that's my problem i think we're
going to be very careful about
getting too defined in what we're
we're asking the community we're saying
we've got a challenge
with the previous library we've got a
challenge
with their current james coming week
neither of them
meet the purposes for the future we've
got
an opportunity for some funding do you
want to take that
up but don't you now if you don't then
that's fine
that's a call the community will make
but we need to listen to them before we
make any decisions because
it's not your money or my money it's
their money
and they need to have assignments just
just a reference to that obviously
what's recommended before here
is not ratifying that that amount is
actually going forward
if i'm correct that we're only going
into the engagement
process um the only issue would be
for councillor phillips is it a
fact that the 1.1 million is tied to
a shovel ready application of three
million and
the one million for tara valley
[Music]
the 5.5 million was a qs rougher
cost on screen rate
for a comprehensive upgrade of this
complex um
it will provide you a useful guide
because if the council is in mind to say
no let's just push the library back to
where it was and do the 1.1 million
roof upgrade the question the council
have for itself is
okay then what do you do with james
cameron because that will that will sit
there
and it will look particularly untidy
compared to next door
and i suspect the community will say
council you've got that you've had this
money
50 years ago you need to look after the
asset um and those who've done building
projects know that it's very hard to
just
focus on one thing and not
comprehensively address all the issues
so that's that needs to be i think a
factor in your mind that
um this the problem of this this
building
has is 50 years old nearly
um
exactly on what he said and i fully
support
what he's saying about the building and
he can go and upgrade his buildings on
commitments for four million dollars
i've been in the health industry before
it's just how you go about it and you've
got to tell your people
that are preparing the work but that's
your budget
and they will work in with you and
you'll come up with a good design
and a good answer if you give them 5.5
million they'll spend within 10 million
they'll spend because i know how
architects like to make glorious
buildings
it's like that facade out in front of
this building here are these big pillars
forces on that building they wouldn't be
there they're a waste of time money in
space
so you make it functional but you don't
do any
fancy rubbish at the front which we've
got out the front here with this big
colors up there
they probably cost 50 or 60 grand to put
that in
i'd wipe them out tomorrow with the
digger boom
don't need them they don't do anything
for the building only cost you more
maintenance
so let's keep the thing to the real
basics what we need
and deal with that and then you'll get
your four million dollar project over
the line with any trouble no flowery
stuff
nothing that's what i wanted to say here
today
as i said the initial bit written down
here is almost work for work by transfer
pharmacy
so that's fine mr chief i can just
just briefly respond to stupid
we've got and i've said this before
we're going to get ourselves out of this
trap of making decisions before we talk
to the community
but we we're assuming that everybody
thinks like
us as individuals actually we're elected
here to represent them
but when we get to a decision like this
then we're going to go into neutral
and that's that's part of the rules that
that we work under
and we need to understand what the aims
and the desires
and the limitations that the community
sets on us
or for the use of the building into the
future
and out of that whatever the cost is
um
i guess to be fair as a council
consultation is not one of our strengths
in the past and i think that
we've got to be much more focused on
engagement
rather than just consultation and
engagement really
means starting at the at the beginning
with a community or with an effective
and in this situation and we're finding
ourselves in one or two of these
situations but in this situation
where the timing of this is forced to
pass
but we've still got time to talk to the
community now
there's ideas that have been floated we
need to share those
and we'll be told very clearly i'm sure
whether people like them or they don't
if they do that's fine if they don't
then what's the alternative
because we've got a very limited time to
make use of this money and
if if people say we don't want that then
that's fine
um well it's not fine with me um but
it's
it's fine and that that will be the
process and we
as a community then will need to sit
down and talk about
what are we going to do with this
particular
complex and what are we going to do with
the library and how we're going to fund
it
and my guess is that it won't be much
short of what we're talking about here
in terms of dollars and will be totally
funded
by the rate parts uh over over a period
of time
and like just to illustrate on my mind
anyways illustrates
the change of use of facilities over
time
this very room room now beneath the
floor is the um
there's a lecture there i suspect in the
last six months
this room's had more use in those six
months that it's had in 10 years
so it was it was needed and it was had a
really good purpose
um when it was built i'm not sure that
purpose is quite
the same now and when you think about
what
the future will be and whatever we do
we're going to have to design something
and
and cater for changing requirements
in a building like this there's some
very fixed definitions around the rooms
the size of the rooms and the use of the
rooms
uh whatever happens either here or
across the road at the other library in
the old library
you know there's gonna have to be
multi-use designed into that because
the way we work now it's not going to be
what the future is
but we can't sit around this table and
pretend to be experts
we need to just hear what our
community's designers are for
a library and for meeting rooms into the
future
if those two coincide then that's great
if they don't then so be it
let's have a look at some other
alternatives
that council read council based thank
you
counseling um i'd just like to
think that when we do put this out for
consultation that
perhaps the angle we should take i don't
mean angle per se but
you know we need to think of it as a
community hub and will we have our
library
enclosed within that hub i think that's
the
you know the public need to understand
that the
use of the rooms will still be there and
maybe we do or do not include the
library i just
i think it's all in how the public gets
to that
point that
the usage will still be here but they'll
also have the benefit of having the
library
close at hand as well
what's the process i'm going to ask sony
what's the process from
here as far as concept
concentration what does it look like
um it looks like launching with
next week on a digital platform with
advertising
across
[Music]
um so i suppose our aim is to get
that social license um for the council
then to move forward
so will there be any visuals like we've
got some great examples of other
libraries around the country that have
massive community spaces in within the
library
which would go some way towards the
garden club's concerns
and possibly other users concerns as
well
so are we going to are they going to be
able to go and look through some other
examples she has definitely
visualization's very part of a very
large part of trying to to promote and
stimulate the conversation and the
ideation
so um yes i'm just waiting now to get
some um
[Music]
because um through human's chair the
library the future library is
more about community space and a library
it's not about
the library it's more about the
space that's available to the community
within that library
thank you councillor oh yes
mr chair i'm just wondering if the
submissions will be open
to other community use for the library
and will they know
um that we're going to borrow
another 1.1 million will they have that
option as well to make that choice
or is that to come later
i mean how i'm just trying to clarify
how all this will be put to the public
so that they can make a decision whether
we
go to the right place for that extra 1.1
that's a secondary step so as i said
before
my introduction remarks the consultation
engagement process is designed to give
community feedback
so around the library and community
space
and what it should look like and that
will help inform the design team to come
up with
a plan and with that plan then you come
up with an updated estimate whatever
that may be
at that point at that time it would be
to the council say okay
this is the subject of the community
consultation here's the concept
here's another estimate what does that
mean in terms of our overall
budget uh do we forge ahead or do we
change the game plan so that's really
the second response
i have another question as well um
so if the if the community decided to
change the use
and not they didn't want a library there
that funding
is not available any longer for the
upgrade of the
game's coming week through you mr
kevin i've yet to receive the actual
funding documents from the government
they've been a bit delayed
but bear in mind two things one that the
project was
promoted to the government on the basis
of the library
come community rooms
and secondly because it came by the
council and the council
signed off on that concept before
funding applications sent to wellington
it would it would probably be difficult
to change the game plan so substantially
still retain the funding but that's that
would be a
subject for further conversation with
government should that
rise so mr
question around time and introduce it to
steve
um once we've engaged with the community
and got some ideas and
[Music]
done what you've just said in terms of
analyzing that and
what it might look like in structural
form
and also what it might cost we will
council make a core
going forward will be october
for yes we're good to go no we need to
revise our
strategy
council um thank you fully support what
nipple is saying
about the money expenditure and
everything but i suppose the bottom line
is
we've asked the community are we moving
the library back to its
existing like normal location or are we
not
um i know what personally
i know the trades is just starting to
slow down now
um so you're just sort of looking at
people who are still restructuring
building companies and all that so are
we going to have the sustained amount of
money still coming into
family homes we
i know the money's great and it'll be
nice to have but do we is it the right
time
so just in response nick um
irrespective of with this concept flies
or doesn't
um we're still gonna have to find a
permanent home for the library
and that's gonna require expenditure
if we were serious about providing a
facility that's going to
cope with the future needs of the
library
and if that means going back to the
original site
that's fine it also spawns the
discussion about
what we do next door or what we do here
actually
uh and how that's funded
[Music]
we've just got to be got to be careful
about whether we
um or how we how we approach this
is either an opportunity or a problem
and
make the most i believe make the most of
that opportunity
that's presenting itself to us now
thank you mr don't get me wrong i'm not
driven by money on this
this project if we can get into the
library into the building
and the community wandered into this
building that's fine
what i'm saying is that is it affordable
that's the most important thing is it
affordable
you know like we've got lots of projects
to come forward
and there is going to be big expenditure
we've only got so much to
come from
unfortunately as steve just said it's
probably a wrong time probably
scenario if it had happened last year
would have been as good as gold wouldn't
it we would have been
fine i think
i think we can do this
on the budget of 4 million if we can do
this on the budget of 4 million
then everything will be great it
wouldn't be a problem
if that four million
gives you what says they want then
that's fine
yeah exactly but if four million doesn't
then then we have to seriously think
about where the money comes from
and is it the right thing to do or the
right time to do it
that's right and then that's not to be
fair
not now no no but what i'm saying
yeah but it's the recommendations that
are important to me
for this meeting that i don't agree with
and there's one or two things i'd like
to change in them when we come to that
part
so any other counselors you want to
cast um thank you mr the way i see it
if we put the library back where it was
we don't
we don't get the three million dollars
plumbing so that's gone you can forget
that
then you've got to still upgrade that
building and then you've still got to
upgrade this building at a cost of
goodness knows what to the right payer
and we've got to fund
all of it if we have the library here
we've got guaranteed four million
dollars worth thunder
we can't turn that down so i think we
need to go to
the community for consultation on the
basis of the library is in this building
with the community spaces
and when it comes time for the for the
plans and what have you
then the counselors can get out their
pencils and say well
what about the budget it's going to be
around you know
we want it to be more like four million
instead of five
that's the point where you can you can
say
and we can argue the toss over the
budget but i think
for for the purpose of this meeting we
need to
agree
[Music]
[Music]
was just look this is an idea already
this is the price um we hope we get a
lot
we've got a fair decent head start
towards it and mr
i think before councillors put
themselves into a corner
and have hard and fast positions um
i would encourage them to think about
the other aspects that are going on at
the moment
with government funding that may
soothe the financial outlook of the
council
there was announcement yesterday which i
was going to give a briefing
to um
that attaches money uh
significant portions thereof uh to our
three waters area
um bear in mind also already gave us a
million dollars that we would have faced
with our next budget for
the issues we have on non-sports complex
they even have been taken care of
so it's easy to look at this in
isolation but look at the wider
picture now obviously the wider picture
will
come into full view as we prepare for
the next long-term plan
and by december we hope to have some
kind of
rough indicative budget for the next 10
years
but just be aware there's other things
going on that potentially could have
a soothing aspect council's financial
forecast
um with this october 19 situation
because there are a number of projects
mr chairman that we're still waiting on
confirmation or otherwise
september
just a question rather than
an observation i use is that
um that note around the 5.5 million is
rough order costs
that's that's really just reflecting
be updated as the plan
emerges following engagement and you
notice that the words here
are note and the only two aspects you're
asked to kind of give approved to is
an engagement plan in public and
the design team that we want to bring on
board
who have done a student job with the
civic administration building next door
mr chair i think i would prefer to see
that the rough order of cost be four
million because then if it's more then
you can make a decision about that
1.5 million over in a birthday
we don't
[Music]
at a very rough order of cost when the
application has been made so it's going
to cost you around about this
so that's that's qualified figure but
that doesn't necessarily need to be the
figure that it ends up at
but i don't know that we can just say
rough order of costs gonna be four
million dollars because
it may not be like three might be
five who knows so why do we have to put
the fight i've done one replying this is
reflected in the recommendations
adapted here is obviously not for that
amount
that's fine but that's not really the
discussion for today
we could just note that the budget the
council has a budget of four million
dollars
for the project we could just put that
and then
that possibly
[Music]
yeah yeah which is a question with a
travelling
i think it's very important that we
don't mislead um
either um public on either side of the
divide
this project and so
i wonder for completeness whether it
should be that
uh the count that you note just lost my
screen
you know that the um
funding for the project uh is four
million
and then the current rough order of cost
is 5.5
so at least alerts any reader that there
is a gap
that needs to be breached well therefore
therefore mr chairman that we take out
then the balance of be contributed by
the way of alone then
it's written in there that decision has
to be made by the full council mr
chairman
and the right pack
so as we see the recommendations uh
i'd like that i'd like that bit removed
mr chairman the rough order yes thank
you
no no the ballot contributed by the
council by the way of alone
so at present we take that paragraph
until such design is a decision has been
made
so it would have been confident just to
note that the council
has confirmed funding available
from the provincial growth fund of three
million dollars
and material milk walk of
958 i'll be happy with that
we're going to be governed by what the
community wants if the community wants
a 9 million library and building
that's fine if they only want a three
million or they don't want or they want
the liability to go back
that's fine by me too
i think we're going to be careful that
when we're talking about this project
we are immediately jumping to this is
the library project
i think in my mind anyway the community
spaces
that we're trying to create are every
bit as important
as the library because i will be the
key to the future in terms of spaces for
community to use
not just for engaging in library
activities
but all sorts of other activities like
flash shows
which would no doubt encompass the
discussion in regard to
uh community consultation on what the
community rooms
and what they actually wanted the james
comey the part of
that parliament because it's not just
to see
[Music]
financial contributions
and the other two women
statistics
[Music]
someone can look forward
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um it's such a difficult time um not
knowing what the future will be
seeing the government putting money into
these projects for our future
and me seeing and with my team and
training with customers
how important a resolution to this
problem is
so i appreciate you whistling with this
it's essentially difficult
um for me i think it's actually the
perfect timing
because we wouldn't have got this extra
funding
[Music]
um
um
thank you councilman um it was a good
discussion
[Music]
and uh i think uh there's an interesting
time
for the community consultation to see
what everyone wants and
where we're gonna go with this i think
we must get engaged with the community
and get everyone
to concentrate about the library because
at the end of the day it's for their
future
offer only for us i think as councillors
we have a role to make
in terms of consultation and slash
engagement over the last
10 months
[Music]
lot of interest in this particular
project and
and who knows what will come back to
council
in two months uh
decisions but just a question to the
crimes person
[Music]
um
um
you don't have to go very far to find a
good example that's 13 k's down the road
where we joined the library and one
other building together with the hall in
the middle
and it's been very successful and if the
plans can come together
to do the same thing great let's do it
but it's got to be within four million
take the opportunity and get in there
and explain what your good
needs and what requirements are what
would be there because
you know it's part of the consultation
process
[Music]
is
oh thank you mr chair um yes we've had
three successful workshops with the
public with
people who registered to be there and um
i attended two of the three workshops
and they're actually
a huge cross-section of the public and
people came with some great ideas and it
was facilitated
very well and i just i was really happy
to see the
the positivity that it generated people
were excited um
very keen to put their ideas forward and
just
work through the process and i think
they've
taken it on board really well and peter
standring
and the rest of the team ramesh
have been very um vocal and
just about the promotion of it but
certainly not pushing their own barrows
as far as the public goes it's
definitely about by the people for the
people
and um yeah i'm looking forward to the
ideas that we've got so far i'm sure
that there'll be
further consultation to come and lots
other ideas that will come out of those
consultations as well
it's it's really nice to see the
community engagement i think it's been a
very good move
thank you so i'll just reaffirm what
that council reads center
in the workshop on thursday and um
[Music]
many years of policing this town it's
quite interesting that the
ideas that they give you around what you
had preconceived ideas of
yeah where streets work is quite
different
sometimes so um i think it's very
positive it's a great
funding initiative that we've gone into
and as the council
was also noticing this report there's a
engagement um caravan that's coming as
well which will
no doubt suit purpose well so
on saturday and there was very few
people there but they were quite vocal i
thought that ann
pollard run the workshop extremely well
um and there was some good points as
well i reiterate what you're on
saying it was
um it was quite interesting out of the
two nights
that there were some ideas that just
rose up and across both nights
and so it was quite interesting to see
that a lot of the members of the public
were
thinking along the same lines which sort
of gives confirmation to those
projects as they move forward and i'm
sort of hoping too that with the caravan
um we could possibly use that for the
library consultation
in supermarkets or places like that as
well is that a possibility or not
um it was their initial aim but i think
just given the time demonstrates
um that type of certainly
thank you
just recommendations
and the third item is obviously the
post code 19 response from our console
marketing manager
some of
um
i don't think anyone's quite sure it's
going to be able to connect
particularly with the economy and
various bits and pieces but i see um the
work that's going on in there it's been
uh has been
quite economically done and i know it's
been a great commitment from
the council staff and getting it just
greatly taller so i think it's uh it's
been a great routine
a great team job there so if someone
would just have another discussion
[Music]